ready for more gut filled in your life
greg's brand new weeknight show debuts
this monday at 11 p.m eastern
and he's set to rattle the late night
landscape check out his
face plastered on a billboard deep in
the heart of hollywood overlooking
hollywood boulevard greg
you've been crushing it on the weekends
you're going to crush it during the
weekdays i'm so excited for your show
thank you katie there's going to be five
times more crushing
because saturday was just one night you
got five nights by the way if i had
known about that billboard that's across
from
jimmy kimmel's studio i would have i
would love to have done my own
i would love to have defaced my own face
would have to draw a mustache on there
would have been really fun but i love
where it is
um and by the way katie do you remember
the first show you were on
red eye right red eye yes yes
the key to the gut felt show is like you
we always look for new people we always
look for
for people that had like you were fresh
out of college i think and we
and we're and because now we're on we're
gonna have more guests and be able to
take more risks so you're gonna see a
lot of interesting and unusual people
that you don't normally see on tv
well i'm looking forward to it trey one
of the problems and challenges i have
when i do the five with greg is that i
have to
reserve my laughter because he's so
funny and i don't want to be obnoxious
and so i'm looking forward to some late
night comedy five days a week
from greg rather than these other late
night hosts
i am too katie i but i do want to ask
greg two questions and one is one is
serious and
i used to be a prosecutor and i think i
owe it to the american people to ask
this tough question greg your critics
and you have some but your critics have
alleged that the only way you got this
show
was based on your your good looks your
charisma and your sex appeal so how do
you respond to your critics that that's
the only way you got this show
you know i'm so tired of hearing from
them but
in this case you know they're right
they're right i mean
how else do how else could this loud
obnoxious creature
ever get on tv if it wasn't for just
being gorgeous
i mean
one serious question the funniest people
i know are often introverts and it's
much harder to be funny
than people think is that true in your
own life i mean it
it's hard to be funny all the time i i
don't i
i i all i do is i just speak what's
running through my brain
so uh oftentimes it's not funny but it's
the whole point of comedy
is taking risks so every time you open
your mouth you're basically jumping off
a cliff and you never know where it's
gonna go that's why cancer culture
is so damaging to people who are
comedians people who go out on stage i'm
not one of those people i've never done
stand-up
i've always been in publishing uh uh
packaging
magazines and books but uh it's it's a
scary time
to be a free thinker
that is true juan you don't agree with
craig on much but i think you can agree
that he's a beautiful he's a beautiful
face which is why it's on a billboard in
hollywood
so true i agreed with the 13. i tell you
that
you know what you know what i i was
thinking greg you say
you say you're gonna have new people on
there and i was thinking well
this week we had new people we have
jesse waters
junior i know he's born april 1st he's
going to be a fun guy greg you got to
get him on the show
here's the deal how sad is it that
jessie waters had to undermine my new
show
by having a child like this was supposed
to be my moment
juan this was supposed to be my moment
this whole week was about me and then he
goes and has a kid or his
wife as a kid on april fool's day and
then he names it after himself
it's crazy
shannon i'm telling you very competitive
very competitive
yeah listen i'm excited about the monday
launch i could not possibly have a
better opening act than greg gutfeld i
mean he is going to jam up those numbers
and have people laughing across the
country we are foxy's at night is moving
to midnight and the east coast will be
nine o'clock pacific
uh and i can't wait to see what you do
greg cause i feel like so much of what
is quote unquote
um comedy out there just not funny these
days and i think i don't care who you go
after just at least make it funny
yeah i mean they all they're all
drinking the same
juice but i'm looking forward to coming
up with great transitions when i hand
the show off to you
uh there's a lot of things that i can be
awkward at all no not at all
it's it's gonna be you can do a lot
there's a lot of rhymes with bream
i have to tell you i've been looking
them up you're right